Java code has a special way of saying things like me or my. It's this. We have
this reference. The this reference can be used to distinguish between instance
variables and parameters. Or local variables, which only belong inside the
method. This, no pun intended, solves a problem that we had earlier. Remember
in the constructor for the person, we had to give the parameter this odd name,
aName. If instead of using aName, we had just used name, then this code would
look like this, which won't work. If we name the parameter the same as the
instance variable, then this one just assigns the parameter. The value it
already has, nothing changes. But you can access the instance variable using
this. If you write this.name equals name, then you'll assign the value of name,
the parameter variable, into the instance variable. In Java, local variables
and parameter variables are considered first when looking up variable names. We
say that a local variable shadows an instance variable. The instance variable
is hidden in the shadow of the local variable. And to find the instance
variable again, you need to use this. This dot name equals name means set the
instance variable name to the value of the parameter name.